rara vez es maccarti y sta moi
debilitado como líder de la Cámara
de los deputatos sufriré la humillación
de rondas de [ __ ] de voto antes que pueden
realmente dicen que se unen como presidente
de la Cámara de Diputados
solo la quinta chitarrese la historia
estado en agujas que mastroronda
exhiquido y el equipo de primera era
en el siglo XIV no se le negaba
vota catorza y ​​se siente desierta
cuatro años y en 1852 durante
la pre-guerra civil entra en el
importante concesión básica que es
En resumen, cartas al zerbed y tiro.
diputado los de Estrella una emoción de la
senura par destituir al presidente
de la Cámara, así como debilita mucho su
red social Ahora siento que una
persona de quien ese otro miembro de
diputado de cámara usted no es el que tiene
un Algo que propone McCarthy puedes
dedicar a menasar De y presente
una emoción sensorial
a la cámara de diputados Pero sí que un
mermato mucho y del presidente de la
Cámara de Diputados
además del punto smui controvertidos
orada entra el trabaco que se acerca y
para probarlo la evasión del texto de la
deoda y yo era una luz muy fuerte Entrar
democratas republicanones sin embargo tambien
Entre los republicanos Smiths había sido
visión de la pobreza ambientalista y la
figura del expresidente Donald Trump
Mientras que maravilloso fue
incidentes a seguir tambien elpresiano a
Nogal varios votan un Paul McCartney
estoy revisando al confrontador
particularmente con el resultado de la
selección del pasado Tonio lo proporcionó
Hugo el grande
la conquista roja debe ser
Republicano de Senago y de la Cámara
de los deputatos con pidió sólo el
cámara de diputados y disparar una marca
muy pequeño pero si eso es mucho
Scanditos presentados apoyados
Desafortunadamente
est pero creo que no es suficiente ni
mucho por qué por supuesto